[Music]
for agriculture the manpower that
comes from abroad is very important
this team of Romanian ladies
are essential for me they know how to do their
job they do it perfectly when
last year the borders were closed
and the only possibility of  to get
our team of romanian ladies was
to make an airlift from high
tyrol to romania and on the way back we
contacted a businessman from bolzano
who kindly made
his private jet available to us he is unfortunately
among the individual member states of
the european community  there was no communication
and this made everything very very
difficult it
is very important that the borders
remain open because
we cannot find the manpower on site and we have to
get these teams who come
from abroad because by now they are
specialized I hope that in  future
closed borders that these crimes do not
happen again
because there is the risk of
completely blocking a compart  or very important economic
[Music]